[Music]
in woman vs. wild news ooh submitted my
but submitted my submitted by Bart man
good job Julia thank you I was like
Danny would notice
Bart man instantly made me cool in first
grade because at first I was the guy
with a weird name
Bart Barton and they started calling me
Bart but the apartment came out it was
for coming Bart man
just that recent like Bart Simpson from
The Simpsons yeah they just wanted an
excuse to like yell Bartman
thing yeah it's it's Bart's character
but then him being Batman yeah he has a
mask and everything in the cape yeah and
you ride the skateboard so people just
wanted to say is when they saw me no
because I don't have TVs I don't know
what the talk about okay oh you didn't
watch the Simpson I don't even know what
they're referring to I just knew they
were talking to me in a very cool tone
you know TV you know cable you know we
know we my TV was taped up by my mom so
I was never able to watch you be going
up yeah that sucks a bit something you
see that your friend's house or anything
oh wait it's on I like it was that like
8:00 p.m. yeah too late
so a 25 year old woman survived on
berries wild mushrooms and muddy water
after being lost in the woods for
berries mushrooms and muddy water yeah
this sounds like a dope blues band how
does she know which mushrooms to eat
because I think it would kill me in
berries like I'd be scared like that
Mary looks dangerous that look is the
owl give me a rat
I'll get you a choice and muddy water -
yeah muddy waters haunts me getting
stuck in her lungs I know
muddy she probably got some [ __ ]
parasites knew she was watching what the
animals we oh that's smart
where does she learn her survival skills
from I want to know we
here the story because my dog likes
drinking gutter water but I would never
put my lips on that [ __ ] gasps oh this
woman her name is Lisa she's 25 years
old she got lost in the Alabama
wilderness after running away from these
two men and so I'm not sure like her
relationship with these two men but
apparently these two men told her as
they were on their way to a camping
ground that they were going to rob that
site and so she was like I just signed
up with his [ __ ] robbery [ __ ]
yeah and then she just booked it she
just ran away from them and so the guys
were arrested shortly after they robbed
the camping grounds and good for her she
predicted the future yeah and then so
they were they were saying half of the
future she didn't realize she's gonna
[ __ ] why did she run to the Ranger's
office I'm not sure where was that she
ran away from or like how she even got
lost but she did and when the men were
arrested they were the cue of the
persons of interest in her disappearance
and so they were just telling them like
look like she was with us but she ran
away when she found out we were gonna be
doing this and so we haven't heard from
her since and so she was missing for an
entire month until she until there's
this woman named Judy she was driving
along the highway and then that's when
she saw something moving in a bush when
we pulled over thinking it was a deer
and she went over herself
huh it was Lisa finger-banging herself
in the bush well the bush was shaking
you said doesn't get laid very much who
would stop for a shaking bush yeah I'm
saying do you guys stop when you see
cars pulled over to the side
I just say I hope someone helps them
yeah I'm from LA I think if I was a
dancer at all from LA there's a burning
car and someone's yelling help someone
will help I did know one person who
would like pull over for it like anyone
even like hang out good people you I
don't know I I worry for her because
like she's like a sweetest person and
when she sees some know people like that
exist there's so many people in the city
that's why I'm like Oh care of them yeah
Julia's friend stranger danger man mmm
yeah Julia's fine we'll get raped on my
behalf what what raped on your behalf
doesn't that mean or robbed or kidnapped
or whatever whatever would happen
mentality like oh like she'll take it
for the team yeah yeah fucked-up people
juice little tiny people so Judy was
curious and so she pulled over Alabama
in the countryside I guess yeah and the
[ __ ]
yeah so then um she goes over and she
finds a naked woman covered in scratches
and Angie Lee fights her hair was matted
there was dirt in her now that she
looked like she had been living in the
well for a long time is what powered a
ran back in my car [ __ ] came women in
this area I saw sasquatch yes so then
Judy says that she just started shaking
and she was just like she was crying she
was scared cuz she don't know what to do
so then she told her she went over to
Lisa and said like hey can you just stay
here for a second I'm gonna go get water
out of my van she's so nurturing I would
have been like what kind of [ __ ]
crack are you on yeah
like this girl's on crack yes there's a
shaking bush at every corner no going
over to her van calling 9-1-1 and then
that's when he came over they identified
her as Lisa and then they were saying
that she had been reported missing for
over three weeks and they're just saying
like they they're not exactly sure how
she ended up and the wilderness or like
all the details because immediately once
they found her they just wanted to make
sure that she was okay so they just took
her to the hospital they didn't
interrogate her or anything so details
are still coming out from this but here
I'll show you guys some photos I need to
I need to know like after she's well
rested and all that or I'll be like so
how come you just stick to the main road
well hiding from the guys they're saying
that she just got like from being out
there for so long she ended up becoming
you know because she was to try to be
food and water so she just kind of was
like disoriented what are her clothes go
I want to know the same thing it's the
mushrooms she ate the mushrooms highest
[ __ ] the clothes started burning her
she's like I gotta get this fire [ __ ]
loin cloth off of me and she took it off
and then afterwards she started rolling
around on the ground and all like these
twigs started [ __ ] her up and she got
bit by bugs talk about personal
experience they're also saying that she
lost 50 pounds whole this is before she
got lost right she's made it to the news
and they use they chose her Hooters
picture just the first one I showed you
it's like a snapchat so he's like why
not your graduation there's so many
pictures they go to shows you got to
choose right I know where it shows like
her whole body just pretty eyes yes
those were
it is actually look like when she was
found though she has nice eyes she's
happy she's found - how does she turn
from white girl to black girl she got
burned
oh she's got a tan I bet you that's what
Jesus looks like just like brown and
dusty I mean like okay so she's been
okay three weeks no grooming right but
her face is still like her lips are nice
or complex you yeah there boo she put
there nice her hair is all like she look
at that yeah it's like natural nice give
her a modeling contrast to her skin yeah
she looks good that's gonna be the
newest trend get lost in the forest for
a week I mean a month and then there's a
pound come out with glowing snow but
then this is what her back look like oh
well see you know it's a fight it's all
the bugs spines cookie family saying
that not an introvert was like not
affected or every inch of her is
affected and then I forgot the second
part but yeah every inch of her has been
affected because wow that looks great
this is the highway she was found weird
it her clothes go I don't know just do
it off maybe that wasn't keeping her
warm but she took it off the pie could
have got wet it rain she had to take it
off she got sick
maybe three weeks is a long time if you
ain't got [ __ ] to do yeah the cops are
saying that they don't want it call it a
miracle but especially with no survival
training I don't think I could live out
there for three weeks these are the men
I beat I'd be too hungry after the first
day these are the men that she was with
they look like stand-up citizens the god
no left looks familiar
he does huh there's a familiar look so
late that's why yeah
[Laughter]
yeah they stole over $50,000 worth of
goods from the camping ground including
and like a TV the chainsaw and I don't
know not a capped out there how do you
store ATVs doesn't have at least track
yeah maybe that's your gonna do i watch
it once you get on the road maybe who's
about I guess but they didn't get away
but they can't get that far that's so
dumb
I think I'd starve to death the first
day the first day cuz I mean I can't
survive off mushrooms cranberries and
[ __ ] water
yeah but I watch people do it I don't
study the skills of it and usually my
[ __ ] consists of going there with
camping equipment some of these guys
they know how to live out there with
Matt thing like they just know how to
get a stone and then they like chop some
wood with the stone make a hammer with a
hammer they make a shed with that they
like they know how to do all these
things they know how to like we will
[ __ ] basket and then throw it in the
river and then there's like fish that
come in I think I'd be alive I'll try to
study that part what part did you study
then oh I just watched them do it but I
don't know the step I don't listen to
the step by step yeah if I don't find a
hamburger within the first four hours
I'm dead hamburger yep so every day you
need to eat a numbers are it I better
find like a big-ass Big Mac under a rock
or something get a leaf Mack yeah yeah
with a possum in the middle I want to
learn survival skills just in case
things like this happen where I'm liking
a car full of guys and they're like I'm
gonna go rob some [ __ ] and I'm like Matt
and I [ __ ] jump out the car and roll
like this and fall down the cliff that's
the point where I die
just keep rolling yeah you cuz you never
know it's one of those things where it's
like you never know when you need these
wilderness survival skills but it just
happened but in LA oh I don't huh in LA
we don't really need them I know LA
survival skills yeah yep just got a raw
people hey guys would you think of that
video I know you loved it so make sure
to hit that like button to watch more
videos and check it out up here
[Music]